Hey Youtubers it's Charlie. Happy Doctor Who Week! So in honor the 50th Anniversary
me and a bunch of my friends are doing
special Doctor Who videos every day
through Saturday.
So today I'll be doing my TOP 5 Doctor
Who villains of all time.
Be sure to SUBSCRIBE to get all the
videos. I also have info on the description
starting with Number 5 - The doctor
himself. So I know this might be cheating
just a little bit but
I always considered the greatest heroes to
be their own worst enemies. River Song
even said during Series 6 that the
Doctor's one of the most feared men in
the universe.
and during the 50th Anniversary
we're going to meet the Warrior Doctor
John Hurt.
Number 4 - The Master. Sherlock Holmes
would not be the world's greatest
detective
without Moriarty and the Master is the
Doctor's Moriarty
The Master has done everything from mass
genocide to things resulting in the
death of more than one Doctor and
possesses his own measure of
Regeneration.
The Time Lords even granted him a new
regeneration cycle in exchange for his
help during "The 5 Doctors".
Everybody who wants John Simm to come back in Series 8 or Series 9 raise their
hand.
Number 3 - The Time Lords. So I know
this is another controversial choice
but the Time Lords are one of the most
destructive forces in the universe next
the Daleks. President Rassilon even
claims that Time Lord's created black
holes
which are the most naturally destructive
force in the universe.
president last line even went on to try
and in time itself so that the time was
gonna send to higher state being
and on the other side of the time or
number two the dollar X when the only
other doctor who builds to possess the
ability to time travel
dollars to one of the most fearsome
Doctor Who villains just because they're
so willing to alter their own biology to
Chi perfection
and i'm not the Sacramento they're
completely willing to kill members at
their own race that they deem to be
in perfect they also possess a high
degree free well making them a really
unpredictable
and now my all-time favorite I could
have done the Weeping Angels
unlike a lot of other doctor who go on
you can even close your eyes around them
have you ever tried to toppling for more
than a couple minutes it is
agony you can even poke your own eyes
out because then you wouldn't be able to
look at them
it only make the argument that angel Bob
and Statue of Liberty angel are just a
little bit silly
I think that only within the toner Matt
Smith more physically comedic doctor
it's impossible to do a top five list
without leaving so many amazing duck
villains of the less
be sure to write your top five in the
comments below me my friends are also
doing a special live stream with BBC
America on Saturday
that starts at 2:30 p.m. I should add a
link in the description is since we
posted
right now check out some the awesome
videos that my friends are doing on
their channels by clicking on one of
these
imitations thanks so much for watching
a/c guys tomorrow
iPad them